all right it's nine o'clock in the
morning right the day after the attendee
party so we're all sharp my name is
Richard Campbell I normally make a lot
of podcasts when I'm here but we're only
making a few this week so I was able to
squeeze a talk it as well and this is
the building trust Athena's talk is the
one I chose of course I have my
caffeinated beverage because it is early
cuz I'm from British Columbia I know I
speak like an American but I'm not I'm a
Canadian I'm you know from the colonies
my house is on the left the house on the
right is my neighbor's place we call
this camera the animal highway because
there's a force behind it and this is a
Wednesday morning about 6:00 a.m. and
Wednesdays are garbage day in my
neighborhood and so this guy is just
coming to check to see if I put out my
garbage early they I don't think there's
any bears left in the UK is there I know
I was trying to find like do you have
any reference for black bears but you
know she'll see the background there
he's actually standing atop my driveway
surveying his domain and if that doesn't
get you this is the same camera a year
later got a little bit moved and we
didn't know that bears came through
pretty much every week until we put the
camera in cuz they're pretty stealthy
but this is not a bear any guesses it's
a juvenile mountain lion it's about
thirty kilos of cat and this is a small
one anyway that this is one made the
news cuz you know we're used to bears
bears are kind of a normal thing moved
to the neighborhood you nobody gets
particularly freaked out unless they're
out like during the day when the kids
are around but nobody likes a mountain
lion
so that's fish and wildlife came out
they didn't find him he was a juvenile
he was lost he should have been in the
town in town but that was fairly
exciting so that's what it's like living
in BC just wild life all the time and it
was in BC I wrote my first line of code
in 1977 so I may be older than I look
that is not the most important thing you
have in 1977
the most important thing happened 1977
was Star Wars right keep your priorities
straight the computer in question was a
trs-80 model 1 and only had 4k of ram a
cassette tape player for storing
programs on and a version of basic that
was not made by Microsoft it was a tiny
basic and it only had three error
messages what how I'm sorry now you'd
say print divide one by zero would it
say sorry which i think is still a very
polite error message right I am Canadian
after all you know the difference is
today now we have gooeys and stuff so
it's not enough that Windows tells you
you're wrong it also makes you agree
with it
registry is corrupt ok
there's no not ok button and let's face
it if your registry is corrupt it's not
ok but now you have to agree with it I
do spend a lot of my time
making podcasts and I think there's a
few dotnet rocks listeners in the room
so we have thanks my friend Carl
Franklin started up back in 2002 which
means he predates the word podcast by 3
years I was a guest in in 2004 and then
in 2005 he asked me to be the co-host so
I stuck on the co-hosting duties his
show 100 there are two co-hosts before
me Mark done to the first 50 Rory
brought Blythe was co-host in the second
50 when I was a guest so I figured when
I came on at 100 I'll do 50 and we're at
16 72 so closed in 2007 I also started
to show called run as radio just for IT
pros every Wednesday since April 2007 we
published shows over at 673 of those and
for a brief interval from 2011 to 2014
when we weren't sure if dotnet rocked we
made a show called the tablet show it
was our contingency plan when Windows 8
was coming and we were all sort of
uncertain to the future and and I was
trying to figure how to talk about
tablet stuff coherently and
so we put it in its own show but by 2014
it was clear that dotnet did rock and we
rolled the tabla show back into Donna
rocks alright and another aspect of my
life that again I don't generally talk
about what for this topic is relevant is
I have been involved in a number of
different business ventures in a variety
of capacities you might have heard it on
the show if you've listened further back
but a company called strange loop
networks so it was a startup we put
together actually in 2006 we were making
appliances for making websites go faster
so taking everything we learned through
the dot-com boom about me making fast
websites I've actually built it into an
appliance and that company got acquired
by rad we're in 24 ed 2013 I also sat on
the board of tol Eric today you know
them is progress they went which
programs acquired tell Eric in 2014 and
I'm these days it mostly involved in in
ventures as an advisor primarily in an
example of that we could probably you
haven't heard of called vortex and
actually what we're doing there is we're
trying to build Expedia for containers
so shipping containers right now largely
if you need a shipping container to move
something from China you know to Europe
you're gonna you're gonna order it via
fax really and so the building good
software that will allow you to find
what containers available on what ships
at what prices with what services that's
the sort of things we're working on so
I've always had a strong business
background working in different kinds of
companies and working with lots of
different teams that being said I don't
feel like I'm an expert in trust I don't
know how you be an expert in trust the
reason this session exists is because of
a podcast the the guys at sequel data
partners asked me to be a guest on their
show and I'm not a hypocrite so if
somebody asked me to come on a podcast I
say yes you think about how many times
in a given year I ask someone to come on
a podcast it's somewhere in the
neighborhood of 200 right so yeah I'm
gonna say yes and this show ended up
being about trust the story the story
they were talking from the context of a
DBA who was working with a group of
developers and trying to convince them
you know
we can improve the performance of this
application by changing some code as
well as changing some aspects of the
database so they were doing a little
entity framework work and they thought
if you do some store procedures but
you're gonna have to make some changes
and we managed to talk about doing it
made a difference in the app and then
they said great let's go start on the
next I'll go hang on there and he said
well what do I got to do we've clearly
demonstrated this and so I started you
just started with hey look one point of
reference is not a line you know Trust
takes longer than that and then an hour
went by and then after that show was
published the folks at the past
conference the big sequel server
conference asked me if I would make that
into a talk and I thought okay what did
I say so I listened to the show and took
notes from myself which is weird and it
turned into this but really sort of
foundational material for me the way I
learned to work in teams I'm gonna
reference three books and I'll throw
this this picture of these three books
back up later in the deck as well and
I'll mention some of the elements of it
in the center the classic the seven
Habits of Highly Effective People or
Stephen Covey's talks about sort of
three things you can do for yourself so
about being proactive and beginning at
the end in mind and putting first things
first three things that you do in a team
thinking win-win seeking first to
understand and then being understood
synergizing or valuing the difference
and the seventh habit being sharpening
the saw which is what we're doing this
week right that we take time away from
work to hone our own tools our own
capabilities to think about what if
we're working on the things that matter
to us you know and the sort of story is
a guy trying to cut down a tree with a
big saw and it's taking longer and
longer because the Sol's are really dull
and somebody says why don't you stop for
a minute sharpen his sauce this is I'm
too busy cutting down the tree
can't you see so we have to take time
once in a while to focus on the
leadership of our careers as opposed to
the management of our careers most of
the time you're managing your career
you're doing it as opposed to the times
where you sort of step back and go am i
working on two things
want to work on a my efficient a my
skilled in the things I need for that so
that's seven habits drive I think it's
especially relevant for us in the
technology industry because drive talk
pink talks about that after the basic
bills are paid after a reasonable wage
money does not motivate people in fact
money can become quite poisonous to work
that what actually motivates people when
the basics are taking care of our
autonomy mastery and purpose autonomy
being I want to be able to work on what
I want to work on how I want to work
mastery being I need I need
opportunities to press against the edges
of my skills not just do the same things
each day and purpose that we're doing
something more important than just
making a paycheck you know you think if
we were really just cogs in a machine
that are good at typing we wouldn't care
what happened to the software we made
but we care you know you never see a
more unhappy developer than someone
that's worked a year on some code that
no one ever uses purpose matters and
that's really Drive focuses on that last
of the three here a power of a full
engagement is a interesting book as it
talks about management of your work from
the perspective of energy versus time
there's lots of time management theories
out there and they make the point that
we all have the same amount of time the
question is how do you manage your
energy or more relevantly how do you
recharge your battery so that you when
you do work you work fast you get a lot
done you are charged by doing it well
I'll refer to these as we talk through
this because we're talking about trust
and trust a funny concept you know
humans are kind of hardwired to trust
each other we are a sort of collective
people we're social people and so we
want to trust work from the very
beginning babies cling to other humans
right right from the very beginning
the question is what is trust when
you're put into a situation where it's
useful for us to trust each other how do
you grow that and the best definition I
know of trust is that when we have
shared values so when I know that you
value things that I valued and values is
a tricky one because there are a lot of
values literally hundreds if you go
searching on the interwebs you'll find
out but they're a list and list of
values I could throw out a handful
things like integrity and compassion and
honesty these are kind of easy ones
there are more complicated ones but they
are all values and our ability to share
them with the people around it and see
that we have common ground on that
that's the basis of trust now do you
have to have trust is it an essential
part of work well not really right we
want to be able to feel safe at work
that safety part is our ability to take
some chances to explore to press against
it you can function without safety and
without trust you just protect yourself
and I'm sure you've met a co-worker at
one point or another who is just kind of
walled off from everyone else they do
their work and move on it's not a fun
way to work it's not the most productive
way to work largely because when you're
focused on safety and protection you
can't take any chances
we get back to that pink concept of
mastery I depress against the edges of
your skills is to risk failure that's
the concept the risk of failure is kind
of fun and when you succeed and move the
edge of your skill further forward
that's growth and it makes work more
interesting but you have to feel that
you can fail that you can take a risk
and is an awful lot of employment today
that leaves no room for failure we're in
an exploratory industry software is
young 50 60 70 years old depending on
how you measure it we will be an
engineering discipline one day
and we are not today but it's it's
inevitable we're starting to teach
people as software engineers we're
starting to apply those kinds of
standards and those standards bodies
allow us to work within a framework that
would make for the very reliable
software but while we explore we must be
able to fail otherwise we stay within
very narrow bounds of what we believe
are safe and often fail for other
reasons not just because we hit the edge
of the software but because we hit the
edge of a budget at a time so you need
to be allowed to fail and when I've been
brought in on or into organizations as a
consultant I pretty much start at the
top and say and see what their tolerance
to failure actually is and it's very
common that senior leadership says oh
yeah we're well you know brave move fast
and break things we're willing to fail
and the next year down not so much you
know those those people are a whole lot
more conserved about that it's like you
can definitely fail with no down time so
the comfort level we have with failure
sort of dictates our ability maneuver
that doesn't mean we have to have all of
those things often we wrap ourselves in
the different aspects of our work the
different people in our work working on
software in a product there are products
that define us in some respects not that
I'm not just a software developer I'm a
node developer I'm not just a DBA sequel
server person right that kind of mindset
and it's a way to separate us or
actually what it says is I have a value
you don't have and so we trust each
other less and it's incorrect yes we are
we all use products but our actual roles
within organizations are not product
specific and you are responsible for
creating features and whatever tools
that you're using you're responsible for
shepherding data as a DBA and
responsible for network operations and
stability those are not products and
actually when you really look at
everyone's work and I think the DevOps
move is is helping us to embrace this
idea
we are all engaged in providing customer
value when we focus on product we tend
to decrease our ability to trust each
other but when we focus on customer
value which we all are responsible for
that's a shared value that's an increase
in trust so now that we sort of get a
picture of what it is to explore trust
let's talk about how we interact at work
it is a few different aspects of our
roles at work one of them is leadership
leadership is a funny concept because
it's not it is bestowed but not by on
high it is bestowed by your peers when
they choose to follow you you've
certainly worked in and been in an
organization where the boss wasn't the
leader there was somebody else in the
team that kind of knew their way around
all the problems so the person you would
go to a person that would help make a
decision and we'd all go along with it
that's leadership right I mean in the
end if you you don't have to have any
particular authority you can walk walk
in front and everyone walks the same way
as you kind of leading now there is also
Authority but let's make authority you
know recognize it separately from
leadership leadership is people is your
ability to have people follow you
authority is something bestowed upon you
by another Authority and it doesn't
necessarily have any power per se and
but this is very much a cultural thing
depending on where I am in the world
when you have this conversation there
are places in the world or authorities
everything it's it's simple you guys the
authority leads right in the in the in
the Americas especially where they got
that anti-authoritarian streak not so
much the third aspect and I would think
by far the most is influence so that is
essentially the ability to persuade or
the ability to alter behavior and I'm
not going to say good or bad it's just
an ability and we all have
of all three things leadership authority
influence in everything that we do in
different quantities now really
effective leaders the ones you've
admired use these three aspects
carefully one would argue the only one
of the three you really have control
over is influence is your ability to
affect the behavior of others a good
leader
influences group the folks that should
follow him if at the aspect of your of
those of those three that you would use
the least is authority wise leaders
resist applying Authority the very end
really wise ones wait until Authority is
demanded we have argued this out
somebody has to make the call
you're the leader decide leaders love
that because now because then
authorities not a hammer right I'm not
demanding you do things a certain away
I'm seeing the consensus as far I've
forgotten and I'm calling the ball
because we want to move ahead but we're
rarely actually the leader
we're rarely at the peak of authority
we've all at different times in in the
work that we're doing where we see a way
forward we see a technology it's gonna
make a difference and if only we were in
charge this would be fine let's be
really honest we're never gonna be in
charge that's just not how it's gonna
work out the only way that we actually
take our skills and our knowledge and
our beliefs and apply them to work
successfully is through influence this
is the skill you can cultivate you don't
have to be the CEO to affect the
direction of the company you just have
to be able to affect the CEO that's
influence and it's a useful skill
something you can put your time into and
it's shaped by your ability to
communicate and we're all communicating
all
time in various ways whether we
understand it or not in communications
more complex today than it's been
probably ever because we have so many
mediums once upon a time the only way we
communicated was standing face to face
with each other you know maybe some
smoke signals now we have technology and
that impacts our ability to communicate
it increases our reach when you speak to
more people but at a limited way so and
when a given medium isn't working for
you the trick is to change the medium so
let's work through a couple of
communication paths or exits instant
messenger instant messenger is a great
tool why it is asynchronous I can send
you a message without having to know
whether you're there or not it is non
interrupting you if you turn off the
bell it doesn't have to interrupt you
it's perfectly functional asynchronous
and non interrupting but it's narrow
bandwidth
it's a filming a few characters maybe
some emojis to help but that's kind of
the limit of what it can do and so text
messages can go poorly you know in a
high trust situation if we already trust
each other which is generally the only
time you use an instant message approach
so somebody already know well where you
hear my voice in my words anyway it's
the message where it's great would you
instant message with someone you don't
really know not so much it's harder you
have to sort of explain things it's kind
of a weak medium for that and so when
the message isn't being well received
you change the medium let's go to email
because emails good
now what's great about email it's
asynchronous it's non interrupting its
long format maybe too long now I judge
the quality of an email conversation by
whether the email is getting longer and
reply or shorter if you write me a
paragraph and I respond with three and
you respond with 16 we're going the
wrong way
that is not increasing communication
right this that's beating you into
submission with more words right a good
email chain gets
order you know the perfect ending to an
email is okay or thanks and if the email
is getting longer change the medium a
medium is not working so you could try a
phone call now
what what's wrong with phone calls like
it's funny that we judge we have all
have phones rarely use them for phone
calls well the previous mediums we're
asynchronous and non interrupting a
telephone is synchronous and
interrupting and in this era of constant
demands on your attention we were more
aware than ever in our lives that
interrupting with a phone call is
actually a statement and the statement
is I don't care what you're doing pay
attention to me it's the most important
thing and you're wrong which is why I've
come to appreciate that there are no
phone calls in my life that I want that
aren't in my schedule the phone rings
and I don't have a reminder already
popped up from Outlook that there's a
call coming I don't answer it and when I
do answer it I'm sad but pretty
consistently that's how I did I answer
this because I am being interrupted from
whatever I was working on which was
important enough that I was working on
it for something that almost certainly
isn't as important and if you are
careful with telephone etiquette you
actually use one of the other mediums
ahead of it you instant message them hey
you got time for a call that's the
social niceties says can I interrupt you
right that's now become important didn't
used to be once upon a time the phone
was novel when it rang it was exciting
oh my goodness
it did a thing let's see what it does
it's not like that anymore
we all have them we're all busy and we
have to be respectful of people's focus
and that we already have some humility
over our needs versus their needs right
it's a kind of a shared value they're
right
I trust you not to interrupt me with the
mundane now there's also the conference
call conference call is just like
telephone call except that we spend 15
minutes gay making sure everybody is
angry before we start the call like I
actually took a step back in the end I
was wat you know this is great with
families to like if you ever recorded
the morning cuz my girls they were mean
to their mom so I just started recording
the morning and playing it back at
dinnertime it's like is this really how
we want to start our day going to work
and going to school with these are the
words that were left each morning
well I started doing that with meetings
too it's like what are the chances of
this being a positive and constructive
meeting when we've just spent 10 minutes
cursing Skype we're trying to influence
right we're trying to make progress
we're trying to pull ourselves the same
direction and the tools are impairing us
they're convenient but ineffective until
you can get it smooth enough that it's
no it's it's not part of the friction we
already had friction that's our having a
meeting so reducing the friction notes
becomes really important and then
ultimately if a meetings not working and
you've been to lots of meetings that
don't work if the outcome of a meeting
is another meeting that's a fail right
the goal was to make a decision right
was to make progress to to get aligned
and if that's not what came out of the
meeting
stop face-to-face one-on-one better
meetings lower friction right folks are
remote on the road on a conference call
you know but most productive things
you've ever done the best communication
you've ever done probably one-on-one and
it's very limiting you see it's
synchronous it's interrupting it's
time-consuming but it's fective
but there is a form of communication
higher than the one-on-one meeting and
it's pizza you like pepperoni that's
good like vegetarian okay
ham and pineapple oh yeah all right
Heath heathens anchovy and olive pizza
choice kind of an interesting thing you
know talk about stronger forms of
communication what do you like we're
here share values
apparently I have ham and pineapple
people to share values with humans are
hard-wired to trust the people they
break bread with it's in our caveman
brain that when we sat around the fire
and shared food those our family we
spend our workday working exercising the
trust in our team it's hard to build
trust when you have to count on at the
same time I would argue the only time we
actually have in a given work day to
grow trust that is to spend time sharing
values and connecting on those is lunch
if you're a leader of a team or you're
new to a team are you are in a position
where you need to think about am i well
connected with this team do I trust this
team does this team trust me plan your
lunches they are the single best time as
an external person is a consultant
coming in watching teams the team that
ate together who is more productive
together these are core rituals of
humanity and I'm not saying I want to
manipulate them and said I want to value
them when it was my responsibility the
team yeah I had lunch with my team had
one-on-one in groups you know a group
lunch it's great up to a certain size
you know if if they can't all hear each
other the goal was not to eat food I
mean eating food is necessary but the
goal was to communicate so as soon as
the table is too big and you can't
communicate with each other you kind of
breaking the ability to grow trust
so size matters and if your team's tight
works well with each other
like each other trust each other share
values as a team lead you start reaching
across teams I have lunch with another
team because we have to work together
too
you know there are points of
communication lunches are important
there's only so many in a year plan them
take time on they're valuable there are
other opportunities but this is the easy
one that we can all do just be
thoughtful it's good to have lunch with
your team but he teams pretty stable you
can do more you can reach further out I
like a good lunch and learn where we all
get together and there's a technology or
something to talk about essentially a
subject they can also be a
trust-building exercise the few things
I'd say about lunch and learn is a make
them make the learn part short enough
that we can talk about it right because
the talking part turned out that was
actually the important part also present
them as ideas not fait accompli z' not
saw this new technology I think we
should implement it next week watch this
video right great way to alienate to not
build trust as opposed to hey what do
you think of this and then you can talk
about it
alright come at it from equal footing
whatever form it it comes in there are
people who value privacy in their
lunches that they it's a it's their
downtime when you know we're in an
industry that that has a lot of
introverts in it you need to be able to
recharge batteries and sometimes that's
all on your own I appreciate that and I
think it's important and you can't do it
all the time because we're also social
creatures we also need to build trust
and so schedule those too you can do
both inviting teams to come and make
presentations to other teams so one of
the best things I ever did it strangely
was we were doing the hard part about
that
building an appliance making websites go
faster you have to put it in a
customer's Network and every customers
network is broken in some way the
hardest job is strange looked by far
were the system engineers we're the
folks that had to make the appliance
work and in process debug the customers
network inevitably and developers who
are absolutely convinced they have the
hardest job in the world because they
are creating new things just did not
appreciate how hard it was for an se to
be successful the product no different
than an Operations person's like hey we
built a software there monkey boy
deliver it right make it up and running
and so we did cross team meetings we had
the devs sit in on an SE going through
the process of an installation just so
they could see it alright at the same
time we did with the SES like how do we
build and test a feature with a with
operations teams about how we monitor
and maintain the goal of every one of
those meetings in my mind as the leader
was for the two teams to come out of the
lunch going wow your jobs hard thanks
for doing it and an appreciation of
what's hard there's a shared value right
there that we appreciate the effort that
each of us put into those different
roles then all of those roles are
important that we don't get to provide
customer value until everyone succeeds
in their role then you have some
appreciation for that you give some room
for it to take longer to have problems I
don't know why you guys take so long
deploy the software I mean how hard
could it be hard I would also say and I
love this xkcd comic for this be kind to
people who don't know something because
it's actually a really good day when you
get to teach and they get to learn to be
excited about that don't be dismissive
of it you don't know that or the bigger
sin but don't worry that's easy it's one
of the biggest crimes in technology is
we call stuff easy because it's a lie
and it's undermining someone comes to
use
explain to me this reactive extensions
you like don't worry it's easy right
what do you just said you must be an
idiot for not knowing this and what I do
is trivial and it's not easy it was
actually hard it's like don't worry I
figured this out takes a bit of effort
I'll walk you through it it'll be great
but not easy
let's not devalue our work much less to
devalue others stuffs hard but worth it
valuable those are positive ways to
approach those ideas I am NOT a big fan
of team-building exercises I am sure for
some group of people this is awesome
just nobody I've ever worked with
however there are other ways this is
another aspect of building trust we get
beyond this basic concept of trust
within a team what is the culture of our
team what does our team value there's
all these different possible values and
yeah there's the low-hanging fruits of
compassion and honesty and integrity but
there are more specific aspects that
maybe we should highlight that there a
way we can strengthen our team further
so let me give you an example at Strange
Loop we were mostly developers who are
building new technology at least half
the company we're software developers
and they worked best at home all right
that's their controlled space we want
them to do original thinking we had an
IRC channel that was sort of our chat
but every Friday everybody came into the
office and this is code review time this
is when we go through what we've built
so far and talk about what's gonna
happen next week all those things of
course I'm going to feed them because
you trusts who you eat with we only got
one day a week together I'm going to
strengthen that so provide food and I
believe that nothing succeeds like
excess so there's a lot of food and the
leftover food was created on discomfort
for certain people so you know it's the
end of the meal we end up eating we're
still
knocking we're ready to move on the next
thing and more than one of the folks in
the room we're like can we take a few
minutes I'd like to take this down to
the soup kitchen the leftovers
I'm like sure that seems reasonable got
a lot better than throwing it away and
you know we were in Vancouver and
there's no focus folks down and out
there and food's appreciated and so just
became let's take 20 minutes folks run
this food off to to go to the various
places that will take it and it'll help
people was a value you know a cultural
element of our team that was important
that we're respectful and useful with
food what can I do with that like it was
a hint of something because I want to
build more trust lunch we can do some
with but if we were going to go outside
of lunch we're gonna do more what would
we do well knowing that food is
important how about we do a soup kitchen
or this was actually a Food Bank if
serving your community this way is
important to your team let me tell you
what's great about a food bank it's the
dullest dumbest work you've ever seen in
your life you've got pot groceries on
one side and boxes on the other side and
it's like to lima beans go in the box to
craft it Kraft macaroni cheese go in the
box like within a few minutes the
average programmers gonna figure out the
routine but boring is good because the
goal was to talk and so suddenly we're
all in a line working on something we
value something important but little
trivial little easy and we talk to each
other and the team got that much
stronger we tried it with soup kitchens
- same thing you know serving up plates
not that hard you got room to think room
to explore room to get to know each
other you know one of the things that
came out of these kinds of exercises
nicknames a nickname kindly given is a
manifestation of a shared experience
when that nickname is deployed at work
it's a reminder of trust and the same
thing I saw teams where everybody ended
up with a nickname
really strong teams kindly given there
are mean names to I should have changed
up the Christmas presents because of
that we give we essentially would give
gagged Christmas presents sort of
collectively as leadership for whatever
terrible silly thing happened right
whatever that may be
so you know the guy who lost his keys
down the drain trying to get to the food
bank we gave him one of the pink lips
it's like here just clap your hands when
you hear that beep that's the keys you
can't get to but that's the sort of
thing right reminders of when we've
worked together when we trusted each
other anytime we can remind ourselves I
have this group of people I care about
that I value that's a strong team I also
did Habitat for Humanity which is tough
because you know watching a great
software engineer paint a fence like no
ok I'm actually pretty good electrical
wiring so they were all surprised he's
apparently I'm not actually good at
anything but boy I could pull some row
max this brings up another aspect though
we certainly ran into this with habitat
humanity this is a whole weekend right
you mean we were to start up we're
already working long hours and then you
know on the weekend you're gonna go
team-building right this is a spouse and
the guy and that the employees like
listen I really really I think it could
be great I can't do you know I can't go
home and say hey I'm gonna now go spend
two more days with my co-workers have a
good time with the kids now there's an
answer and the answer was pretty easy it
was child binding all right go home I'm
gonna take the kids with me all right I
paid for a little bit of child mining
right for a couple of professionals to
do face painting and drawing and so
forth while we were doing the
team-building exercise so that turned
from I'm leaving you again over the
weekend to hey go play do whatever you
want
I'll take the kids and then realized
well my children were grown by the time
we were doing this and I didn't have to
supervise but I had plenty of young
families in the company it's like well I
gotta plan this into every team-building
exercise anything we're gonna do out
extracurricular evenings so forth how do
we manage the kids - how do they be a
part of it
if you're a leader and you're putting
together something where you're gonna
include family members in any respect
take a minute and thank them it's a
small thing but it makes a huge
difference you know you've got a strong
purpose and a strong culture around what
you're doing at work with your team when
you get a chance to share that with
their families and say hey then part of
the reason our team is great is the
families that are involved we are all
are affected by those values one way or
the other and including them is
important do you understand the culture
and the group that you have here it's no
different than figuring out the right
pizza you know it's embarrassing brought
pizza into the office for a month before
I found out there were three vegetarians
and we weren't getting any vegetarian
pizzas it's like and then and this why
didn't you say something is the wrong
answer
why didn't you check that's your job
we're trying to strengthen a team and
you're alienating people with pizza like
you missed an easy one figuring out what
people like is important I'm not a huge
fan of the off-site because there it's
because it's a tosser then there's two
problems with off sites the first is if
you include anybody then it's just a
party and we're not gonna get any work
done it's expensive right you want to
keep the group as small as possible the
only time I would do an off-site is when
we're gonna make a very unpleasant
decision one that people don't want to
make and so we would include the people
that have to be part of the decision and
we'd have exactly one agenda item that
decision because if you bring a bunch of
agenda items you're gonna do all the
easy ones and just not get to the hard
one so we didn't bring any easy ones
right yeah you're getting away we I'm in
British Columbia so you know the thing
it was easy for us to do was to go up
into the mountains in a cabin with no
cell service and make a decision because
you kind of undistracted so to get there
but the goal it had to be unpleasant
enough it had to be something hard that
we would isolate ourselves over those
things
there are easier ways to strengthen a
team actually a good off-site is a team
challenge we're gonna go press against
something that's going to affect the
business and it's hard otherwise
offsites get a little unruly remote
workers got all this stuff we do to
collectively and having lunch with and
so forth and you always have some folks
that are remote there's a really remote
like they coming into the office is hard
so a few things that I suggest your one
is they can't not ever come into the
office maybe it's only a couple of times
a year but it has to be once in a while
yeah it's gonna be an expense and
impediment there's a bunch of things you
can do with that too if I have a route
when I have a group where at least one
or two members are always remote they're
always at the other end of the phone I
will also ask other members of the group
to occasionally be on the other end of
the phone if it's four people are always
in a room together in one person remote
the one person remote is other
effectively we make them not other by
having at least a few of the other
members go just into their office for
that matter and call in just to be down
the same skinny pipe of communication
that that remote person was is a little
bit of empathy goes a long way for how
bad the sound is alright one of the best
things I did for the three remote worker
full-time remote workers we had it
strange you bought them high-end
headsets Plantronics a visa
it's a few hundred dollars but it's like
I know your remote but I want you to
sound great because if he's also sound
terrible it's just all the worse alright
good a headsets I make make it's trivial
so it's a couple hundred bucks and it
makes every communication better the
other challenge was remote workers is we
tend to only communicate them when
there's something important which leaves
them out of the social piece so you know
tools like slack and IRC and so forth
have helped with that where we're all
sort of communicating the same means
that the watercooler is now digital
that's good but I also made a point and
I still do this to this day of having
coffee with a remote
hey I'm about to go get a cup of tea do
you want to go get the beverage of your
choice the biggest point is video on No
Agenda that's the point right
we're just consuming our beverage of
choice in chatting you know it's hard
you're usually used to honey don't
forget about that wait we're working
again as opposed to what we should be
doing which is sharing values all right
kids
what are you doing you know though in
the weekend like that's what those
things look like right those
conversations ultimately are what
strengthens a team and includes a remote
worker I've also had remote teams you
know maybe it's a contractor team maybe
it's an ace wholly owned subsidiary
something like that so we have a dev
team in a different country not to make
you know two final points so imagine you
have you have a dev team in Boston you
have a dev team in Bulgaria I need these
teams to trust each other
we do right how do you build trust it'd
be great if you could just bring
everybody together you know hang out but
that's a really expensive and
challenging so we bring a member from
the Bulgarian team to Boston for a month
and then six months later a member from
Boston go to Bulgaria for a month now
here's the trick what member who there
are three aspects leadership Authority
influence what is the aspect it's make
the biggest difference in the cultural
exchange its influence the tendency is
to take the most senior person the one
with the most authority it's almost
always a mistake you want the influencer
my best measure of a junior person who's
a great influencer is who knows the
birthdays of the entire team and their
kids you know that person why when I
bring that person there for a month a
they're now on the other side of the
call right
is sort of fun Hey look here on the
other side of the call and sort of see
what the call is like and then but this
is also the person because they know all
those things about their team they
talked to that old team Wow how else
would they know all that so once they
get back with they're gonna share those
experiences they're going to convey that
trust upon that group that's what's
powerful and it's tricky to pick the
right person and folks are gonna be bent
out of shape based on who you pick to
but it's worth it I need an influencer
when we do an exchange like that that's
what's powerful that's what makes the
biggest impact it strengthens the team
if you can afford to get them all
together do it it's worth it makes the
team strong without a doubt and don't do
it for a week if a person is only there
long enough to get over the jetlag and
come back it's just not effective as
influencers they have to be long enough
that they can actually be comfortable
embracing get off the main okay we have
done all the sites into the eating at my
favorite greasy spoon stage of being
there right getting passed we have a
planned you know going out for a formal
thing everyday that's fun for a week
after a while it's like I'd like to go
bed early tonight like you actually wind
down and get into the routine that's why
a month is powerful you get into a
routine being there you kind of get a
taste and comfort with the culture of
what it's actually like it should be
someone who travels well
you know if you're gonna be sick the
whole time which some people are then
that's not a good fit but those kinds of
exchanges done well everything gets
better it really empowers the team
I know these are lots of different
pieces and lots of different ideas and
thoughts and steps right and maybe it
seems contrived and it's not right I'm
looking for you to do the right thing
for the right reason which is that you
want to be successful and productive and
as a leader you play a huge role you
have to be the exemplar you have to be
the example that everyone looks at and
so it starts with being honest about
what you're doing I am trying to
strengthen this team I think we can be
better I'm not saying we're bad I think
we can be better and I want to try and
that means also owning up when you make
mistakes because you will right it'll
start with if you try and do a
team-building exercise just ask me how I
know all right and but owning up to that
it's like okay that didn't go well oh my
god is it just me or didn't look like we
were having a lot of fun right you'll
know the difference when you get the
right one compared to getting the wrong
one so owning up to your mistakes and
and genuinely apologizing recognizing it
in a real apology has no butt in it
right it's like I meant this this
happened it had this hemp act on you and
I am sorry right
I meant to include everyone in lunch I
did not check to see you were vegetarian
and I that's my failure I know better
than that and I'm sorry I'm going to do
my best not to have that happen again no
buts
real apologies they're powerful right
and that is a shared value
I don't saying screw up so you can
strengthen values that's not a good
system but I'm also saying when there's
a mistake it is an opportunity to share
a value don't waste it
few calls to action taking time we all
have the same amount of time you need to
do the things to keep you well you need
to spend the time well I would also say
control your schedule take good look at
your schedule for a meta perspective how
many things on your schedule are things
you want rather than things other people
want alright most of the time it's easy
to fall in trouble the only thing on
your schedule our meetings which nobody
wants you know and garbage day blocking
out time for the other things that
important to you plan your lunches plan
times to make your team stronger to meet
with the people you need to meet with
there's no fast way to build trust it
takes time
you can get better at it but the main
thing is that it becomes routine for you
to press against trust you're always
going to need to communicate the number
one thing people fail at that they
struggle with is not communicating
effectively and that means learning
about the people around you so that you
know how they communicate and they learn
how you communicate and what works being
flexible changing up the medium time for
self leadership leading yourself that's
kind of what you're doing this week
right you're here working on yourself
right you're learning new things you're
sort of tasting the buffet of sessions
you don't get to lead your career very
often like what else to say just a
couple of days is almost not enough I
tend to take a week away from work to
sort of reflect on am I doing the things
I want to do it takes a while to really
sort of clear ahead of the day-to-day
start thinking more broadly about am I
going the direction I want to go in make
some notes you're gonna get inspirations
mostly you're gonna say I need to look
into X which is not something you'll
normally think about so it's good to
sort of go back and say am i doing the
right thing oh and by the way you are
your worst critic I don't care who you
are you are your worst critic give
yourself a break thing we're all trying
to do better it's all right
make time to learn most of the smartest
people you've ever met most a successful
two ever met big on learning all the
time
trick to being able to learn put it in
your schedule block out time to read if
you like reading no different mediums
for different people some would rather
consume videos some would rather consume
podcasts and thank you
I don't like podcaster crass I'm a
reader actually I read fast I read
voraciously I have a Kindle it's filled
with books you tell me about a book I
simply order it on the probability was
important enough for you to mention it's
probably a part enough for me to read
and because I consume close to a hundred
books a year so I'm gonna get there I
also fly a lot it's just like what do
you do on flights
I read alright I consumed the nokia
history book on the way from Canada here
it's good I highly recommend it but
however you learn learn make it part of
your routine you know it's a one-way
trip new what's new knowledge is in it
doesn't come back out right even if you
don't can't remember it word for word
that's not important your mind is
modified by a new idea and you are the
composite of all of those ideas
the only other aspect I add to that is
be careful with what you learn and what
you read I like these the philosophy of
the information diet that we kind of
want to look at the nutritional value of
something before we consume it because
exactly that same reason even a bad idea
once consumed modifies your mind
permanently don't let them right look at
your sources before you consume thinking
in roles often we're focused on the job
and even push to be the cog you are the
front-end developer you are the node
developer you are the DBA the broader
role responsibility for data
responsibility for customer value
responsibility for creating new things
the roles that were in they give us more
reach into the organization more
understanding you know if you're
responsible for customer value let's
start with do you know how the company
makes money we should all probably know
that and then
you see your role in that rarely in
software are we frontline to revenue
generation right we're staff we provide
the tools that allow the folks making
money for the organization to be more
effective super valuable
we are force multipliers know how that
works that's part of your broader role
being vulnerable Trust is a
vulnerability exercise I cannot have you
trust me if you if I don't trust you
right I have to share a value for you to
share a value with me so all those
things are normal and so you have to do
both there's no easy way you can't be
walled off and building trust bring
those books back up again I hope you
have a great last day of the conference
thank you for your time
[Applause]